alors peut penser qu'après l'été les
choses se règlerait il ya eu des mains
tendues il ya eu des paroles sympathique
et amicale
mais pour l'instant rien n'est réglé
présent la république a présenté un plan
pauvreté naturellement pour les
départements dans le social et l'adn
pour les communes qui sont auprès des
habitants pour les régions qui organise
l'emploi un plan pauvreté c'est
formidable c'est juste
et quid du financement pour les jeunes
majeurs pour les aider une fois qu'ils
sont sortis de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance on nous promet 50 millions
d'euros
ça correspond au besoin d'un seul
département le nord et rien pour les
autres voilà il faut répartir la pénurie